Tursunay Ziyawudun is part
of the Turkic ethnic group
known as the Uyghurs,
Chinese Muslims who mostly live
in the northwest province of Xinjiang.
There are about 12.8 million
Uyghurs who live there,
and human rights groups say
that many have become victims
of crimes against humanity at
the hands of the government.
China is accused of imprisoning
over one million Uyghurs
in re-education camps, sexual abuse,
and even forced sterilization.
Ziyawudun says she spent 11 months in jail
for no stated reason.
She was sexually assaulted and tortured.
Communist Party officials have
attributed their treatment
of the Uyghurs to the war on terror.
In 2008, the region suffered
multiple terrorist attacks
linked to the East Turkestan
independence movement,
which is a faction within
the Uyghur community
that wants Xinjiang to separate from China
and form its own state.
But human rights advocates
say that terrorism
is just an excuse.
The Chinese have oppressed the Uyghurs
as part of their push
for radical conformity.
The government describes
the camps as focused
on re-education and career training.
In 2017, when the crackdown intensified,
Uyghurs were targeted
for wearing head scarfs,
for abstaining from drinking alcohol,
and for displaying abnormal behaviors,
like purchasing dumbbells.
Some attribute the Chinese
government push for conformity
to capitalism, and Beijing's
desire to staff factories,
increase production, and surpass
the US on the global stage.
But the Chinese Communist
Party says its goal
is to build a modern socialist country.
And that description is more apt.
China seeks to impose one identity,
culture, and language on all
of its 1.37 billion people,
erasing that which does not conform.
From the policies of Mao,
to those of Lenin and Stalin,
when command and control of
society is imposed uniformity,
it inevitably leads to
human rights violations.
Ziyawudun says that she felt
as if the Chinese government set out
to eradicate her culture and ethnicity.
The Chinese government has
ever more sophisticated tools
of surveillance at its disposal.
And it allegedly provides
local authorities
with lists that detail how
to identify extremists.
In Ziyawudun's case, she
says she was arrested
when she returned to
Xinjiang from Kazakhstan,
where she had been living
with her Kazak husband.
Ziyawudun says she was released
after her husband advocated on her behalf.
She made it to the US under the protection
of the Uyghur Human Rights Project,
an organization that seeks
to promote the rights
of the Uyghur and other
Turkic Muslims from Xinjiang.
Today Ziyawudun lives in a suburb of D.C.
She says that her heart
aches for her family
and the other Uyghurs back home,
millions of whom are
still being imprisoned,
tortured, and surveilled in
their most private spaces,
including their living
rooms, dining areas,
and prayer spaces,
according to one report.
Although the US has
condemned the mistreatment
of the Uyghurs, and government officials
are boycotting the Beijing
Olympics in protest,
we've admitted zero new Uyghur refugees
in the last two years.
Welcoming foreigners like Ziyawudun
is what has allowed the US to
avoid becoming a monoculture.
And our diversity of
thought and experience
is the secret of American capitalism.
China's erasing of the Uyghur culture
and its decision to surveil, imprison,
and torture the Uyghur people in pursuit
of becoming the leading global superpower